I leave in are you on your way back home
either way we wanna be there doesn't
matter how much baggage you give us time
and made terminal and gate we wanna send
you off in style we wanna welcome you
back home tell us all about it we scared
or was it fine now horn
[Music]
do you meet around
do you need a ride do you need a line do
you need a ride do you need a ride do
you need a ride with Karen and Chris
thank you
welcome so do you need a ride this is
Chris Fairbanks this is Karen kill
Gareth we are I'm just making sure I'm
on the ones and twos adjusting the
levels we're back this is do you need a
ride I already said that we're back
after a what three months hiatus
yeah we've been busy we've been doing
lots of things so get off our backs I
mean first of all first of all we love
that you're on our backs oh yes [ __ ] put
get off it I'm glad you're here now hop
off yeah you know what I was yelling to
myself the other day in the kitchen keep
it loose I don't remember where we were
but used to remember you started yelling
keep it loose thank you I don't know if
it was before if it was like a comedy
festival it may have been a kind of a
Bridgetown thing but what started
yelling keep it loose at each other was
this maybe oh okay now it is yeah I
remember the keep it loose back and
forth I just liked it as a concept it's
keep it loose it's really good advice
like loosey-goosey
yeah just like don't tighten up don't
[ __ ] stress out just keep it loose
right I think we were talking about for
our sets but then I it really applies it
really is when I meant by hearing anyone
doing their art it's because they don't
seem to care about it while they're
doing it that's right so you got to keep
it loose you've got to keep it loose and
even if everyone actually does care
about it and is pretending they don't
but the whole idea is to do it as if you
don't I feel like I was raised and my
mom was always like very tense you know
and was not loosey-goosey mm-hmm and so
I think comedy is good for me because it
makes me be that way yeah if I didn't do
it I'd probably be in a bank with my
jiggling my leg and being nervous kid
what if you would know I'd work in a
bank
that's the only other option you I like
to see you on the stock market ring in
that Bell at 9:00 a.m. or whyever they
ring that Bell
once you ring it though you know you got
a wave a napkin and scream that's your
alternate life this is your sliding
doors Chris Fairbanks you the only other
place you could have gone is Finance yes
on the corner there there was a chase
bank it's really the only reason I said
Bank although I am interested in money
are you have an interest in it usually
once a month I get very interested in it
down the first yes and how much there is
or is not yes yeah yeah that's a that's
about as deep as I get into the finance
game I feel like I have any do you have
any can you double it or quadruple it
you're always asking that I love to
quadruple you know what I'm sorry
everyone I'd mess up words all the time
and you don't jump on my back and then
jump right off I would every time I'd
like I'm that there's a perfect example
I would like to decide start to say
something when I hit with dig and then
she'd just go oh did you say my god damn
it I'm just talking but now I remember
it fondly know you could sue her so many
reasons what you just heard was
porcelain onto my ivories oh my I just
may have chipped my tooth with a mug but
it really did make a gling sound that I
appreciate it you took the hit you're
making a sacrifice I got to enjoy a
clean off your tooth it was very read
instantly
you know that's how I chip both my front
teeth my front teeth stick out and kind
of go upward in a way that doesn't make
sense I've never noticed that um it's
the shame of my existence but I've never
had you in the chair this you just
didn't know I've been a dentist this
world a banker yeah uh the banking
dentist so many yellow suspenders but
the way I did it was both times in the
same are you just cling to your teeth
for the coffee cup I broke out my two
front teeth with beer bottles at two
different parties Wow
yeah how a grip what were you doing when
you it's just bringing it up to your
face laughing or something the first
time it was my friend patty Leone and I
were fighting over who could sing into
the microphone which was a beer bottle
there was a scorpion song at our Tahoe
trip our senior trip in Tahoe okay and
we were very drunk and she we were
fighting we were pulling we were both
pulling us beer bottle as hard as we
could and then she just let go oh [ __ ]
and [ __ ] I just broke my tooth in the
drunkest drunk girl way possible
oh the drunkest drunk boy way nothing I
mean anyone could have done this no
matter your genitals my friend Casey
marks we were in the desert I can't
remember why and why there was a gun I'd
I've never even held a live held one yes
and you you've held them to decide him
don't like just to go and to get to
sleep and but he tried to shoot a
shotgun with one hand like it was a
pistol and I was like oh that's not
gonna and it came up and hit it dumb and
Dumberer did his front teeth to where
they were chipped the middle in between
the both the front but it was a perfect
round the shape of a barrel Oh like you
know what I mean the roundness that
makes me love him and he kept it that
way for what yeah now he's a school
teacher he teaches like kids and none of
them no none of them know he did that or
then he was a pro snowboarder he was
like
I'm pro snowboarder and I would think
that would be the first thing you do if
you were a teacher with a bunch of scary
kids judging you is hanging up a poster
of you jumping off a cliff on your
snowboard because they'd all be like oh
you're cool yeah but he knows that kids
they simply won't be simply because you
want them to do that so they won't I
think he said he said something like
that he's like they would smell the
desperation hanging up that poster and
it would have made things harder for me
so instead I just act like a guy that
could get mad at any moment yes and oh
that's good he's short fuse teacher yeah
yeah smart sure oh I've seen him take
punches and give them to children no no
but when we were children that was
children everyone every everyone punched
children when I as a kid because there
were children sure who cares they can't
do anything they don't have legal
representation that's the first thing I
ask when I put up my dukes do you have a
lawyer no answer me uh here's the two
question question one and I'm holding up
my fists you can't see that how are you
how was Australia how are you I'm good
it was we had the best time it was a
whirlwind ten-day trip we did live shows
they were great the people were very
nice it's a cool city that doesn't make
food with preservatives I mean it's a
cool country not really sure sure AM
continent did they really have like
organic food all the time it's all
organic like the food is a bit it's
delicious but in general for an American
palate it's a bit bland because they
don't have everything jammed with salt
and preservatives and sugar so like we
would laugh about I can love ordering
room service breakfast I know we've
talked about me and hotel rooms a
million times but sure I love our room
service breakfast I love to order like
three pots of coffee and some [ __ ]
toasts are you
but their butter you would open the
package of butter and it was like dark
yellow Oh orange because it's dairy
fresh butter oh wow and everything's
like that and it's just good for you my
skin cleared up great things for how
that's amazing
uh-huh have you seen this what the
health movie that I've been avoiding
watching but I want to see to try and
make some changes I've heard about it
but I've also also heard already
counter-arguments about it okay
so I don't know what to think and
therefore I'm just gonna keep eating
Baja frost I think we all know though
that we should just be eating things
where you know where it comes from it's
expensive and difficult and then it's
like well every meals gonna be a chore
and a mission every day
yes but it's easy to do it if you're
lonely one person lonely I don't know I
do if you're on the verge of I mean
everything's easier when you're lonely
when you know that you have this burning
desire to be around anyone I'm just
seeing if you had like three kids that
you had to feed it's like well we don't
have time for all of you that's being
organic twelve times in a day but here's
the thing you can also be lonely with
children that's the saddest kind of
aloneness is when you're surrounded by
friends and family and people who love
you and you still you're just totally
isolated that kind of cheers me up
because I've been thinking that I'm sad
I've been just coming up to children and
I'm like you're I should have one of you
that's not really the conversation we
have but I really like there's a I went
to a boxing party last night and there's
a sweet little girl and she was just
walking around giving everyone chips and
like serving people she was 29 she was
just a cute no she was three I think
whose boxing party it was my roommates
haircut her no okay but but it was a
bunch of young adults with kids
my gosh [ __ ] am I supposed to have one
of these but I just realized I could be
unhappy and then have a kid oh no then
I'm really in trouble yes and then you
feel then you're unhappy and you feel
guilty because you're making other
people unhappy yeah and I don't know why
that kid was serving everyone maybe
either she's playing a game in her head
called restaurant or she's like oh I
have to everyone is drunk and they're
watching boxing I have to just occupy my
brain because it's just too much and I
have to give chips away she wants
everyone to sober up like it's what you
get in the 40s they would give drunks
cups of coffee and that's know a
three-year-old little girl shouldn't
have to deal with a bunch of Andy a
roomful Andy Capps that's an emotional
burden for her as a child that's too
much
I gotta sober these people up we're all
gonna crash and die I'm sure they're
going to kill me I'm I've just been here
for three years on the planet that guy
couldn't be more Canadian
and then he just seems very athletic and
he has a fanny pack and he was like
Geddy Lee's hot older brother oh and now
he's just launched into a sprint Wow
urban marathoner he's probably doesn't
like that he's breathing in this freeway
dust but he's still gonna get his car do
I feel bad for a Canadian jogging in Los
Angeles me too that's dad yeah those
poor people coming here to this goddamn
Dust Bowl garbage can only to be
deported the minute they good job what
point is it's like I needed a job I mean
he oh it's Emmys speaking of that it's
Emmys Sunday speaking of Joe Oh today is
the Emmys today's the Emmys
what happened days ago I'm thinking of
Fashion Week it's hard to confuse all
these reasons I have these tuxedos it is
hard to confuse them are you going to
the Emmys [ __ ] no you don't care about
that [ __ ]
listen I'm going to go wouldn't you oh
god more than anything I want to go I'm
really I'm really deep and not about
earthly this earthly plane but I also I
mean I feel the need to prequalify what
I'm about to say because I just think
award shows are so [ __ ] lame and I
know that's very 90s Kurt Cobain of me
and cop to it but but I just when people
get excited about being nominated or
winning Emmys I lose all respect for
them entirely and I never want to talk
to them again
that's how I honestly feel one of my
favorite Twitter people is Pat Sajak I
don't know why he's funny but he is and
he said I hope there's some awards given
out tonight in between all the political
speeches or he worded it better no no
it's just an old kind of conservative
game show fart he's good he's got jokes
he's got you know what Pat Sajak's funny
Karen I that's fine if it's a Tom Arnold
you can say be it doesn't mean there so
I really think you should pay attention
to pets a dad he's a crazy Republican
busy yeah he's like a fighty Republican
okay I haven't seen any of that but I
did get a hint of it but he it was there
will be a bunch of people that don't
that are trying trying hard not to be
self congratulatory and so I think that
they will be tonight the speeches
accepting awards will be about
hurricanes and racism think so even if
even if the show wasn't yeah I think
everyone's like oh I want to do like
that guy from stranger things yeah get
some get some stuff off my chest or well
Jim Carrey did it the other
fashion week he's like this is stupid
it's ever or nothing we're all floating
and oh yeah I like that
yeah I do I did want to like it but for
some reason sometimes he annoys me but
yeah his recent paintings I like the
message of like we are me too it's fun
me too it's a good thing to hear but
also I think these days things are our
president is a [ __ ] rated criminal
like people have to be saying things
because I mean I hear it you're saying
it it can be irritating but I do like it
it makes me go yeah thing when people
acknowledge how bad it has gotten and
you know the idea that we live in a in a
world where Nazis feel comfortable to
exist is [ __ ] and [ __ ] and for a
while I was like I'm like I don't even
want to talk about Donald Trump I want
to say his name it's too bad because
it's happening we should we all have to
be talking about it all the time even if
we're all sick of it it it should be
talked about so good I hope good [ __ ]
you Pat Sajak that's where I worked when
I worked on baskets it's over now but I
love that building so much oh yeah it
isn't it's all Frank Lloyd Wright II you
know what it is that's brutalist
architecture ask me anything I don't
know anything about have you seen that
building and I don't know where it is
where it actually looks like a back a
basket a picnic basket where is it I
wish that's where you wrote masks no I
think it's I think it's in I don't know
where it is it's someone if someone
knows let me know direct message where's
the basket building it looks like oh I
hate it when you see cars that got run
into road stressfull who that tow trucks
taken care of it the sights and sounds
of the streets of LA or just the sounds
the sounds about the sights the sounds
of crunching cars oh that's a nice Lexus
yeah do you like this one better
yeah thank you I always meant I know
you're the what you were fishing for us
yeah you bet you had best serve it up
then if I'm fishing well it's just kind
of a big there should be soccer balls in
the back
oh I didn't see the side of it it is
nice there is I did I've been looking at
cars lately and I'm fine I want to get
my main hunt is paid off is it really
yeah that frees up some might as well
replace it with a new payment I mean you
can handle it
yeah and then some well not really I got
to pay for this hip of mine that's kind
of like buying a car
that [ __ ] thing yeah it is like you
have a new car but inside yeah in it in
my paid for my car right around the time
I got this thing installed so you know
you're saying earlier that suddenly
you're into dogs now I am and yeah it's
the same as the kids thing when I see a
kid I'm like hey buddy and when I see a
dog I'm like hey buddy I treat them the
same
do you think that I think Oh Corky's I
think I want to go to Corky's more in my
life that's just something I'm gonna do
in 2017 I have time but I was gonna say
do you think that those things coincided
with you getting your hip replaced and I
just love the idea that you are not in
constant pain anymore it's so much
better I was grumpy often and I knew
that's why but I got tired of bringing
it up all that time like this whole well
it's just but it's a such a bad quality
of life yeah it's like having a little
Donald Trump in your body it's like I'm
not gonna mention this but yeah I'm not
but I feel happier and then also just
having your leg torn off and put back on
mm-hmm
it's I mean people go through much worse
things of course but it does make you
think about mortality and everything
yeah and then it also makes me think
about people who get their leg torn off
without medical supervision
right right happens I mean it would have
been terrible if my leg was in the
position it was without eight men in
there that knew what they're doing you
know wearing goggles and blood yeah all
over them i watch do i watch the video
yes and you're such a mistake buddy I
don't know now
really I
it made me scared but you know you
should be scared and then later on
afterwards the the payout the knowing
what I've gone through and knowing how
scary it was and knowing that it's
important for me to do this rehab and so
if I didn't watch that video maybe I
wouldn't go to these emasculating bar
method classes trying to you know oh
that guy fell in a play oh he's fine
smiling back sorry
that's so embarrassing I know I want to
say hey are you okay but no that's not
what you want to hear no it's so
embarrassing yeah that's my great fear
of falling down in public when he's holy
isn't he yeah he hurt himself darn it
you don't see that that often - there's
a full front flip on a bike that made me
sad it's he's okay yeah but I still just
want to cry oh wait tell me again about
the man you met at the party I yeah last
night I don't you'll see the boxing
match at a pay-per-view house our house
that had pay-per-view dit paid to view
it and then this guy I just started
petting this dog I'm like I really I
like old dogs
I like I think I want to get old dogs
that are just have like two years left
and adopt only those dogs cuz I like how
they are and then he's like yeah they
just make me sad he's like and then he
just said I've been crying all the time
I I just cry during a car commercial if
the right song is on me - you've been
crying lately I've never met this guy
and he was like a met he looked like he
goes to the gym a lot he had a lot of
gel in his hair and we just talked about
how he'd been crying and I'm like man
it's hard for men to make friends with
other men but I feel like I should have
asked for his phone number kind of hit
it off right away immediately saying we
like crying I think he was really drunk
though at the time yeah but still that
level of honesty
I mean and I've said that before there
there are times where you're just
watching that Toyota commercial and they
pick the right melodic jingle and then
they show a father-and-son or something
and then I think about and then there
I'm not thinking about cars though so I
don't know if it's actually a good way
to advertise I think it is because it's
getting it plucks your heartstrings and
so then it you're not it's not about
cars it's about like life a life
decision that's how that's what they're
trying to do right make it be like
what's your lifestyle yeah I think that
is it I just it never makes me to
remember what kind of car it was
a commercial for it's just like oh that
commercial with the one that made me cry
for a little while it was Subaru a
Subaru have those like date commercials
where it'd be like people that were kind
of hanging out and then something would
magic would happen and they'd be in a
Subaru and it that actually made me it
gave me like a teenage longing feeling
oh those ones where you're like well I
want to be in a Subaru with some [ __ ]
somebody yeah I agree there are certain
cars that I think about and that do that
old Subarus old Jeep Wagoneer mm-hmm I
love a Jeep Wagoneer
yeah logging for some family and plaid
couch I never had and then and then also
Suburbans I think about my friends whose
parents had Suburbans yeah when I see a
suburban it's like oh man I wish I still
was just sleeping over people you know
absolutely it's like never you know
sleepovers are so complicated nowadays
they really are yeah there's so much
fighting
yeah and [ __ ] you can't just sleep
anymore and I just sleep over your house
with you getting the wrong idea
stop being such a [ __ ] man or woman we
both decided we cry no let me sleep over
I want to meet that guy I love the idea
of a person like to me that's such a
good independent film it's like two
dudes standing at a party that one looks
like a skateboarder and one looks like
he works in the financial
Cartman somewhere yeah yeah with gel in
his hair yeah I'd like to talk about
crying right away the first thing I
would have grabbed his face I I guess
under the right circumstances I could
have grabbed his face I would have said
be mine forever okay
did you I'm sure you saw in the news but
before I left for Australia this [ __ ]
part of the valley was on fire right you
see any of it I was distracted by the
fact that I was in Montana and the
entire state was on fire but not in a
way that threatened you know there was
pictures I saw a picture of people
golfing and in the background it was
horribly on fire yeah where they had to
be sweating it yeah
no no because the I think that was the
ISO it was these mountains over here so
I came home from work one night because
I work in the valley that way and I
drove and I it was all blocked by houses
and stuff I drove to CVS and when I
walked out of CVS for the first time it
was unblocked view and it looked like
Hell had grown up behind the Carl's jr.
jr. it was like the weirdest thing I'd
ever seen right really dramatic because
you can see the flame in Montana the
entire state was on fire but it you know
there's not a lot of people you know
it's the fourth largest state there's
only less than a million people there so
it's in the mountains and it's in the
forest it still sucks but it's part of
the process this fear was caused by a
kid with fireworks right is that true I
think so he's gonna get in trouble or
I'm confusing it with the Montana one
but you know fireworks are bad they're
fun but you know you lose an eye or a
finger and you'll and you'll kill your
state's if you're gonna do fireworks do
them in the creek that's what we used to
do take him down to the craft
in the creek that's right got a doom in
the creek here we go deulim in the creek
right now that's every boy we giving the
song we took we would take big boxes of
fireworks down into the creek and it'll
be our family in the hospitals and
usually like one or two other
neighborhood families
you can [ __ ] light an m-80 down there
that's what happens isn't it crazy they
go off they go off but like nothing
catches on why why Karen why do they
stay lit how and why firecrackers in
general what when you light a wick on a
tiny explosive why can you submerge it
in water and it still goes off does it
yes oh well I guess it's the way the
wick is made hmm it's yeah I guess they
are so combustible that it goes beyond
the extinguish whole bulb properties of
water I just had an aneurysm that's why
I'm worried if you think that's why I
don't think too hard about anything
because it sends a bubble to your brain
yeah that's so true but like bottle
rockets I remember shooting them and
they propel underwater like little
submarine
oh that's rad and then they cope at the
end and there's bubbles that's awesome
yeah it is awesome I will do them in the
creek do it in the creek they would in
the crater why don't go up a hill to do
firecrackers no that means you're going
up into the mountains and it's it's if
you're in California the mountains have
been bone-dry for eight years and the
horrible irony of this is the only way
they're retreating to the mountains is
to get away from society so they don't
get in trouble if it wasn't illegal and
we could just light fireworks you know
it'd be safer but more people be injured
I suppose well or we could just burn
everything down and then give everybody
fireworks and then nothing would be
flammable and everyone be having a
right all we have to do is tear down
society and become a firework based
economy we can do this people we if you
care about fireworks as much as I do and
I that includes sparklers that includes
punks
belongings burn them further than
nearest reservations fireworks stand
please and buy some black cats and
little tanks
I like those head paper tanks paper
takes her good pickle Oh Pete's are good
everyone used to buy these loud one that
would blow up they're masters of the
universe dolls or whatever I I just
wanted the little pill that you light
and it turns to a black coiling snake
that's those are called snakes I think
right I think they're called black
coiling is that the full name cuz I was
never trained with black coiled snakes
we just called them in the creek we call
them things yeah I think that that was
when I got a firework stand to be safe
my dad somehow hypnotized me boring ones
where the [ __ ] did you have Punk's the
ones where you my kids were oh you mean
the turd on a stick
yes yes I will oh but it is but it is
manure on a wire no and Punk's are made
of poop what yes
since when mid-seventies I think I never
knew that it doesn't smell like poop
does it no no you got to put it in your
mouth and smell it you have to get it
moist so really burn out the F yeah yeah
and once it's in your mouth you're like
even if you've never really had
cow manure and a stick you know that's
what it is yeah you know you got the
good stuff yeah yeah it has to hit the
back of your tongue and it sensory areas
I always have to get gross because I'm a
boy you went one step too far
I don't like risk just boy games
that's my still my favorite thing and so
many people don't enjoy that joke but
though people will say like would you
like some salami and I'll say no that's
for boys or like have you ever played
blank game and I'll say no that's for
boys oh yeah I think it is so hilarious
to talk like you're eight years old and
people don't think it's funny well I
mean it'll get me and Hot Wok cuz I've
been doing exercise for girls oh that's
right and I talk about it I really I am
it is exactly my therapy that all this
squatting and but they fully depending
on the class the and it's always I'm the
only man and they will have their arms
like in a plie position or whatever
curtsy whatever one arm up one arm down
like a ballet arms and I keep mine down
low because man want everyone to know
their business but I don't I also when
you're the only guy at a at a class
that's mostly women I do have like oh
this is good for my hip I don't want
them to think I'm a weirdo and also
during the class I just look at the
instructor like I'm trying to figure out
algebra like it's really you know I
don't want anyone to think that I'm
there to like look at butts you know oh
yeah I say because I was like well that
does sound like you you're being a
weirdo no bearing intently at the
instructor and I'm really trying to do
it right because there's all these
little little nuanced like you have to
focus on certain areas for a next you
can look like you're doing it and you're
not really doing it it's like look I'm
squatting it's like yeah pretend your
bellybutton is touching your spine and
then you're like oh now this sucks and
I'm jiggling and shaking you have to
engage your core
yeah which is something I don't believe
I've ever engaged it right
I mean you can do sit-ups all day or you
can ride on a bike and I do not sweat as
much as in this class where I'm just
doing these little tiny squats it's been
really interesting but it's helping my
hip so much then I'm excited about my
physical future Carrie hey finally I
feel great uh also I think it's funny
you know what you should do in that
class you should wear night-vision
goggles in there don't you think just
really let him know that you're only
there just the let him know I'm serious
I just turned them up just like in
Silence of the Lambs it just [ __ ]
throw those things down have a moth on
your shoulder and turn off the light
yeah you'd be like I'm fine I am NOT a
cream what side what are your dimensions
by the way I'm interested in sewing good
size 14 roomy okay okay time for class
forget I asked I've actually thought
recently cuz I've let my physical
well-being really slip and I was like
what if I joined like one of those
boxing gyms or something that's all
intensely men like almost like strictly
Armenian gangsters you know what I mean
just go just dip into a world that I do
not belong in and go there and I think
you should and also you know when you
are dipped into this weird world you are
surrounded by it will make you because
you know everyone's watching it that's
the thing about a class it's like all
these everyone's kind of eyes are on me
because I'm the odd the odd duck link
what's my line just 70 years old cuz I'm
the odd duck and then they and it makes
me do it and work harder yep that's
right whereas a video at my house if you
like decide to do some tie bow videos at
your house it's not and I have that the
the same effect as a room full of our
minion member that's right here now
first of all I want to oppress Armenian
man yeah did I ever tell you at the time
of car pulled up and a guy just extended
a single red rose to me no that's what
that's terrific it was I laughed so hard
and what's he kind of goofy about it or
was he like being sensual I don't he was
like he seemed like he was in his late
teens or early 20s oh I don't know what
the [ __ ] he was doing yeah and I
seriously didn't believe that it was a
sincere thing but it was happening
anyway and I just laughed and drove away
that's terrific though it was very I
want to drive around with roses and then
just dramatically extend them to
middle-aged women in the car next to you
it's really enjoyable I've always wanted
to drive around with pre-made signs just
in case I was able to use them that
we're very specific like you you can't
turn left in front of oncoming traffic
just a sign that says that so when
someone does it I have a sign for it
you're right there you pull up next to
them and and then they'll be like oh my
god you're right and also why the [ __ ]
do you have a sign prepared yeah when
did you write it's gonna make them
change if you read a sign and it says
you've got away for pedestrians when you
turn right and it and they just made
that offense yeah I just basically
repeated myself well no I get it my
daughter but I do get it I was just kind
of listening yeah to imagine the actual
traffic violation damn it worthy of a
sign yes
yeah and how creative you could get and
then how long would you have to wait for
those things unfold in front of you yeah
but not in front of your children like a
sign that says that and that's just a
dad in a van how did you know oh my god
I have to go to church it'd make him a
better father and make him find Jesus I
know you were asking earlier where the
National cremation building well I know
right there oh there it is ten fifty
five nine it's putting a loved one in a
jar isn't depressing enough come to this
peach colored box come to it oh this
smallest building to hold your biggest
feel that is the most right next to the
lingerie art rock movie poster cuz it
probably didn't say lingerie
it did say lingerie its own it seemed
like it there's a lot of weird buildings
with no windows that are like
gentlemen's clubs around here you know a
little bit intimidating but posters and
I like Underpants let's go into business
do you think that they mean it like
they're framing pictures of both
Humphrey Bogart and a lady in underpants
I really I I need to know more it's
funny how I try I mean it's hard maybe
they're just trying to be more
interesting than the International is it
national or international Cremation
national yeah yeah they had America you
don't want to be cooking other people
know in other countries there's all
different you know customs you don't
want to get yeah yeah it's you don't
want to offend someone first of all yeah
I mean come on there's little
differences what I tried I have my mom's
ashes I don't know what to do with them
I just have them in the corner I've
spread them here and there and let some
of them blow in the wind in my sister's
mouth done you know a I think I got a
drive to Monterrey have you ever been to
Monterrey oh yeah it's gorgeous
nice born there we left we left when I
was young but it would have been a
beautiful place to grow up
that's lovely go out onto one of those
cliffs yeah and let him go into the
ocean yeah but be careful about it like
pay attention to which way the wind is
blowing yes maybe you know goggle again
the night vision goggles to come into
play yeah I think especially midday yes
I really yeah I think I'm gonna put on
night-vision goggles and a cape and
Senate stand at the edge of a cliff and
yeah you know they make the most of that
moment anyway your mom would want you to
say some words yeah yeah just a list of
random art because it's kind of weird to
just have her be in the corner in my
room where I you know fart nest baby
yeah that is yeah I would I would
definitely take her out of the line of
vision when you're masturbating I don't
think it's nice
sorry I don't think you want to train
yourself to look at that and be a part
of that it's just a black box I don't
know which side her eyes are on turn it
away she's still rolling her eyes are
turned away oh this again please she
knew she did my laundry when I was 15
and she knows now
she sees all that black box my mom is a
is in the dining room up above the like
china cabinet and I didn't know until
one night when my eye one of us somebody
made a joke about mom not being there I
mean I got my dad oh this she's here
she's right there
and then I was like oh my god he didn't
say oh it hits at your none at your
house at my dad's oh yeah yeah yeah it's
easier for me to take because it's at my
dad's house right
yeah I wish I could yeah I just gotta
put it I'm just gonna do something put
it in a better route I mean the box is
made of plastic it's not a show box no I
don't think they're meant for that no no
you're not supposed to show off with
your dead relatives to show no one
really wants to see you show it or
telling you no it's not a show-and-tell
it's neither it's just a private box
right miss jerk off Bob it's all those
things I'm sorry mom I'm sorry what's
your mom's first name again Lynn Lynn
that's my middle name
oh really I didn't know that oh why you
should have said it long ago
ly NN that's right mine's James oh great
thank you no no I was hoping you go
that's my dad's name
it is my thing it is it is my dad's name
what yeah Jim have we talked about this
no this is this how amazing it is
amazing this is rare I just said that as
a joke I know I wasn't even really
killed Jim Kilgore Oh Lynn Fairbanks yes
good to meet you god that's I mean we've
always been connected
yeah but this really [ __ ] galvanizes
it mean it's just [ __ ] name come on I
just take it away I'm the one that built
it up and then I was matching your
excitement what's in a name my first
boyfriend was like this I would match
excitement and then be punished for
really that's a specific cruelty he was
very cruel and weird I actually wouldn't
call him my boyfriend he was a guy that
I spent too much time with in the 90s uh
late eighties it was a confusing time it
was a difficult time the clothes were so
ugly yeah you spent too much time with
him I spent too much time with pants
that covered my shoes baggy Junko jeans
yeah did you do to some junk us oh no no
I don't be crazy
I actually it's funny because as a
skateboarder it is such a it is such a
clicky fashion-conscious
you don't realize when you're into it
but it's like there's only certain
things that you wear and it has to be
skate skate around cool brands yeah and
it's so funny I might as well have been
a dude that only wears Tommy Hilfiger
and Nautica or whatever you know it's
just it's the same you think of
skateboarding it's like or like punk
rock kids when they put so much time
into their fauxhawk and they're they're
putting studs on their jackets it's like
wait aren't you supposed to be like [ __ ]
you I don't care about anything
I care you have to spend the same amount
of time getting ready to go out to your
mosh pit show oh where that guy is
making curious choices what works for
him yeah go to the Starbucks drive-thru
what do you think about I love it I
think it's a good it's a good plot twist
in our podcast it's a good I think it's
good I um as you know I've always been
very self-conscious about how much I
laugh on this podcast and I've been
self-conscious about the fact that
you've been more conscious of it and
I've heard you laughing less and I think
I'm less funny really yeah
is that how is that the trickle-down of
this neuroses of mine you try and fix
yourself and you're hurting
well this episode I was just saying I
simply don't feel that way anymore
oh good I feel free because I also I
realized not that many people make me
laugh as hard as you make me laugh oh
thanks so I might as well do it in real
time
my Ripper repress it and I'm not I'm not
getting any enjoyment out of it as if
I'm not laughing yes
yeah like right now that moment was
badly under you painfully I didn't like
it
[Music]
I loved the invention of Starbucks
drive-through I know it's wrong I know
it's drivable isms are supposed to be
supporting some struggling monpa coffee
people that are squishing the coffee
with their feet and a barrel right now
but I might be confusing the wine yeah
it is more wine than coffee but I just
love it yeah to be able to have a coffee
just comes right onto the back of my car
whoops
um yeah we've probably mentioned
Starbucks enough that on this podcast
that we should be getting something from
them just free coffee Starbucks should
do we would be great and I think is you
know if you're at Starbucks sometimes
and it's music and then you're also
being forced to overhear conversations
they should play our podcast at
Starbucks as the dominant conversation
and then people can talk under it so
that you don't have to listen to some
adults conversation you can listen to
larious fascinating conversation via us
yeah and they'll still play Sarah
McLachlan or whatever sure that can come
in and out yeah yeah mostly it's us
talking all throughout Starbucks across
the land and and internationally because
I did find Starbucks in every city that
I went to in Australia oh did you oh
yeah I looked it's there I and you did
you hang out with you you were just
saying they're kind it's kind of like
Hawaii and everyone is relaxed and kind
of for lack of a better term ivory I
never said you said they were a little
Iman I think you did like remember you
did that offensive accent and you said
ah yeah and I'm like please stop doing
that carrot but I said no eyein says and
then you were like well I think they
don't like it that I'm I oddly I did
this there's some a movie called the bra
boys they're like kind of this
rough-and-tumble gang II surf group of I
don't know how poor they were though cuz
every they had enough documentation for
this documentary that they all had video
cameras so it's like I didn't grow up
with a bunch of video cameras yeah yeah
how rough was it for them but anyway
they one of them was like going to
prison he killed someone but he still
was in this contest and beat Kelly
Slater or something but [ __ ] and and
they are scary but they I went to the
red carpet thing and interviewed oddly
one of the producers was this guy from
Montana it was just a weird thing I hate
it when I start a story and I forget
what direction I want the point is just
in it they made me do like oh I want to
audition for the narrative movie and
Russell Crowe had something to do with
it so he was there and they were gonna
make a movie based on this documentary
on the prow boys yeah I don't think they
ever did but I was like doing an
Australian accent because my boss made
me do it for having hair sorry no it's
okay quit fidgeting Carroll I it was but
I really worked on it to where I was
like mark I'm gonna audition for the
movie what I want to be one of the broug
boys that whole dumb angle but then I
really worked on my and they actually
were all like that's not a bad accent
okay well I was just I was like bloomin
onion yeah no yes Crockett you know I
was saying that stupid [ __ ] crikey but
Russell Crowe and I think it was just on
the heels of Russell Crowe throwing a
phone in a hotel or beating someone I
don't know he was the nicest person ever
really yeah I real
like Russell Crowe everyone was nice yes
guys had like I'm gonna murder you
tattooed on their neck and they would
listen and they were sweet and then when
we were done I was like thanks for doing
that and they're like no thanks for
coming here I appreciate it they were
all I was like Australia love it they're
not a whirlwind tasmanian you know like
you always think i always think oh it's
like the Wild West and everyone's like a
little crazy you know cuz the Tasmanian
Devil well I feel like they might be a
tad bit racist and sexist in a way
that's like they're just behind about
seven years sure that might be a thing
so it's gonna be the next thing I
brought up really yeah but I will say
that on the heels of saying that we just
hypocritical every every single person
we met was the lovely Ryerson that's so
long as you're not an Aboriginal term or
how is that the way that their what is
their relationship to like the native
folks there I don't really know I was
only there for ten days cuz in Montana
it's mostly everyone is white so if
you're racist you're just being an idiot
or you're it's the it really is the the
kind of racism where it is someone being
what's the word ignorant ignorant thank
you good god what's not the word in that
ironic where do not what's that word
that means you don't know any better
but Shamrocks
I just have to mention a thing from the
place right yep you just name a thing
I've always been uncomfortable about
where I'm from people its openly okay to
be have animosity towards Native
American people I don't like it
it always bothered that's so weird yeah
and I think it's still a little like
that I think San Francisco's like that
with Asian people yeah everyone's got
their thing like I'm not racist
well except with the thing that exactly
applies to where I live yet but
everyone's that way do you
yeah I'll just have a iced coffee okay
in the uh you know the medium-sized I
don't want to get nervous okay
no milk enough um no I'm off the cow
nice I am
yeah I'm trying not to try and have a
clean flavorless Aussie diet I mean I
definitely felt better when I came back
I was like this is because also everyone
is so good looking there
they're so beautiful it's crazy well
that's one thing I've noticed about
meeting Australian people here is
they're easy on the old eyes yeah for
real on the old they're very
inspirational in the old boner
Department guy or girl let's sleep over
another one of these high-maintenance
sleep over yes
I wish we were kids he didn't have to do
this what if I said that during sex
Everest we were kids I mean remember
when things were simple I'm done they're
still pretty simple we're kids we
wouldn't have to do that so depressing
it is kind of a little bit goddamn fun
to be around you know what I will say I
did have the oh wait a second I'm sure
to remember this at the end of this
order sure
can I have a grande iced coffee yes and
also a grande mocha iced with just one
pump of chocolate sure one fun
[Music]
no just the coffee no thanks no thanks
that's it she would get her name for the
credit we're gonna have to have you sign
this piece of paper yeah no mine I might
ask you to cut that part out okay yeah I
can do that cameo I mean it takes a
little longer but is it a big pain it
all is all fit all that's a pain I wish
I'm I'm I'm I'm not that guy that is
efficient in that sexy way oh my god
[ __ ] [ __ ] thing I'm doing that that
way during stand-up even I just keep
finding that I say things on podcast
that I'm like a month later I'm like why
I don't people don't need to know that
about me
right saying things trying to think of
something interesting well that wasn't
that revealing I mean we've been
blurting out stuff it's way worse than
one pump of mocha please and now do I
have to cut that out
it's not that embarrassing it's one pump
you know what we'd have to cut out can I
have an extra three pumps of mogh that's
right
it's okay just my hand just your hand
everybody nobody hits your hand
everybody aah
I want a man with us Aloha is this song
about defending yourself I want a man
that's not going to hit me too quick so
I can get away you know an easy touch
you know oh yeah that's funny
let's break down lyrics on our next
podcast we should we should have
multiple punch that song actually was
popular when I was like 10 and it made
me very uncomfortable I was like this is
about sex and we shared a car listening
to it right
with Annies gross it's none of my
business north pointer yes it's just
you're making me think of my parents
[ __ ] yeah this discussion is not for
my ears yeah oh man there's so many
songs from that era that it's like the
only people I knew that had sex were my
parents upstairs so all those songs were
super gross I don't want my dad to have
an easy touch on my mom slow speed up
those hands Pop's get it over with
faster
no Chris you said you were on the road
for six weeks
I was yeah tell me give me a quick and I
mean quick oversight of where you went
what happened oh let me see I gotta go I
went to San Francisco and did some shows
I love that city what sounds like urine
it was just shows in bars that we did
this just some shows it wasn't not
nothing no but I then before that I was
in Tahoe which you mentioned and that
was around the time that the whole tiki
torch white nationalist [ __ ] was
happening and I was in Nevada you're in
Nevada you're not in there's a
difference I'm sorry no there is but
everyone around me looked like those the
kids and that group and I was like mad
there but and you're in a casino and
that's depressing and it's cigarette
smoke and an elevator but then you can
go out the back door and just hike up
mountains and I got all into hiking I
got these cool hiking trail shoes and it
was good for me it was like a healthy
time in it let's guess you know that's
what I gleaned from it nice the audience
there was 15 up and it was good for me
to be in front of nice people that want
to enjoy the thing but they're old and
dumb and no offense
Usami and in Tahoe I it was good and
there were some podcasts people that
drove all the way from somewhere and
they were sweet but really yeah yeah
that always happens it's so cool that's
great it's always just one or two people
but it's cool to make them it's almost
like the it's it's this small mighty
group of people who are like we're
standing
by you guys even if you don't put out
your [ __ ] right right right
it's really nice yeah I mean when we
don't put out for podcast I get I get
tweets from people like all week long
well I figured it was nothing compared
to well now I'm gonna have that tonight
I feel bad for Sinead O'Connor
I I thought it was nothing compared to
what you get my favorite murderer that's
gotta be you had to like you have to
like filter those right yeah gotta be so
many yes and it's like okay there's some
crazy stuff oh yeah there was something
the other day that I read in passing
wasn't even really paying attention and
it bummed me out for like a week and it
was just a thing like it was two people
talking I don't know why I was on it
just like someone and it was just a
shitty comment that was very i'm sure
specifically about you oh no about the
it didn't really matter it was the
podcast but it was one of those things
where I was like it's you can't there's
that side of it then no one ever talks
about because everyone's so badly wants
success people want something good to
happen in their life that they pretend
like there's an but there is an equal
downside to the upside and you have to
get right with it right very quickly
even though you there's no training and
there's no real way to do it you have to
very quickly get used to being discussed
and being open to being talked about by
people who aren't I think for you right
now the ups with as far as podcasts no
it's so good for you right now I'm
excited for you and it's got to be
exciting then fun yeah go ahead and
bring on a few bad things yes like you
can't see too precious it's pretty it's
pretty cool what's happening
I think kinda makes me wish you and I
had done a theme like the Alzheimer's
thing but then that would have come to a
close a traumatic one yes yeah a double
dramatic I guess this is kind of wraps
it up for us
you know but that would have we would
have I don't know it doesn't there's a
lot of responsibility in that yeah we'd
have to we've we would have had to have
done a bunch of research I would have to
reel it in I would always feel bad feed
being ridiculously silly and wanting to
talk about
farting in front of a box it doesn't the
reason that thing hit is purely what was
happening culturally not purely but like
there's so much more to it than just
what we were doing it was my plan yes
just like we put this thing up it was
just like anything else we put out but
just because of the alchemy and the air
yeah you know well I'm glad we do this
one I'm glad it's about nothing and we
can be silly yeah that's right
yeah well that's that's the most fun and
you can just do whatever it is fun I
want to do whatever and just have fun
yeah why is that so [ __ ] wrong oh
sorry there's no theme sorry we're not
picking up someone at 4:00 a.m. at the
expense of our own enjoyment there is
times another part hey Delia hate it
hate it hate being there hate it hate
having to book people that we don't even
necessarily like we have me my person
yeah well I'll start saying names armpit
ripped open no you have to take a
swimming class with a bunch of women oh
I can't wait to go tonight I'm gonna
really work hard you promise mm-hmm
gonna make my belly button touch my
spine
I'll show you pull it all the way back
oh I forgot my grippy socks at least
socks with rubber on the bottom I'm
supposed to wear look at this gorgeous
money they have down there it's
transparent it's there's a strip of
see-through there's the Queen of England
they're very booming bird looks very
much like a Canadian five-step smaller
pretty nice right my favorite is the
Canadian five looks a lot like that now
there's a transparent thing but the old
one with the hockey players is my
favorite because it says that quote
about
of the blasphemy yeah the my years they
might the years of my youth were spent
in school in church and on the ice and
it was the year days on the ice that
matters the most and it's on their mind
it's like hockey yeah it's [ __ ] great
can you my mean that's the last thing
our country would allow hey which either
way it's like you're saying [ __ ] you to
school and church it's pretty bad uh
that's just but that's the kind of
thoughts that guy we saw what the fanny
pack has in his head is he jogs that's
right that [ __ ] guy thank you will you
do my straw for me here I won't touch
your heart you can put it on turn the
cover it's where it is that's another
research our firework Punk's made of
manure and then you put them in your
mouth to prove it that's the second part
of the question I may have been Maya
comedy that's not in the oh that's it's
a piece you're working on no it's one of
my skits it's not in the routine yet is
it it would you call it a new chunk
there's nothing I want to hear anyone
talk about less than a chunk they're
working on yeah ever I know I hate
comedy oh yeah the other night that's
was like how can I run this bit by you
and I'm like oh no but then he did I was
like oh yeah that will work
sorry i booby-trapped your phone and
said it it turned out to be an okay bit
yeah I mean a miracle just like yeah
that'll work I guess why don't you do it
and then it didn't work ah well also
because I have never understood people
asking that question when if anyone ever
anyone is ever going to say to you all
anyone will ever say to you when you ask
that questions yeah that's good because
you have put them in an insanely awkward
position and they don't want to deal
with your dumb [ __ ] no like it's
such a weird pretending that it can be
any other way
yep it's true you're putting someone in
a weird
and they're going to lie to you yeah
they have to yeah you're making them lie
to you yeah don't make people lie to you
stop it stop a specific person we're
talking to right now
stop it Larry don't I don't know anyone
named Larry that's why you know I saying
that at the end of my act just was like
oh I'll just put the name Larry here
when I had a joke about if it's just
like oh my uncle Larry is back from the
army or whatever and then I realized I
do have an uncle I have two uncle
Larry's you do and I was I was not
thinking of either of them it's just a
name I say and then I kept saying it and
then I was like oh my god what if my my
real uncle Larry that's alive heard this
and thought I was talking about him you
are yeah I wasn't though it's just a
name
a name that I plugged in after the word
uncle and then it happens to apply to us
very specific person in my family right
that's how names work I think it's
amazing that the second I say I don't
know you work out your chunk you work
out a chunk on me who I did that just
kidding oh god yeah what if I try what
do you think should I take that one to
Tahoe it wasn't good was the uncle Larry
chunk good it's more of a comment on
it's meta and I also went to Winnipeg
Canada for a festival and it was really
really pretty there was it already cold
it's no it wasn't it was hot but it was
crazy if you're not that far I was
thought I was further into Canada than I
really was you're just like right down
by the border yeah yeah but it's still
one of the coldest places in the world
yeah I think it gets really cold there
cuz it's a proximity to those goddamn
lakes all those Mike's even the finger
ones yo yeah they'll finger it right up
those legs and when they get small
enough they finger right up
we're being saucy on this episode we
only have a little little spicy don't
care that's what it is it's the new this
is the fall 2017 Dean it's very
different
yes its collection what I wanted to say
and then you
I said it hurt made me laugh mm-hmm wish
I had said it anyway we're coming up on
this hour here
coming up on the hour yeah we should
have the idea that do you remember the
first time we need to hold somebody we
were gonna do an artist I mean yeah the
way I think it was destined Martin the
way he stared at us
with no expression on his face oh right
I don't think that could have ever been
a possibility no it was too depressing
yes I agree even just now when I said it
I'm like you know what maybe that's not
true I guess what I was thinking more is
it was like I I do like that we have a
freewheeling unscripted thing but I do
appreciate when and I'm sure you do now
to when there is a format and a and a
theme and I'm yes but I do like you know
I have fun on these other ones where
it's all scripted out and edited but
it's not as fun to do that's all a
scripted podcast yeah or not scripted
whatever look like thoroughly themed so
you're playing a game or like it's very
exact exactly usually it's a game yeah I
get that
no cuz you did you just did
international waters yeah that's there
that's an example perfect one I love
that show
yeah it's very fun but it's like you I
you're not you're not loosey-goosey but
they thought this last one is really
loosey-goosey yeah so never mind
that god I hate it when you don't have a
point you kept it loose that's always
your point yeah here loose cable loose
it's good for your health that makes me
think a is something about international
waters Oh England
Dave Holmes [ __ ] I did it when I left
Michelle balloon and then she went to
visit with you that's right after where
it told me about it yes no it was it was
more about oh I can't remember I guess
here's what I'll say this is my advice
to anyone who is starting a podcast or
has a podcast that they think could be
doing better somehow yeah just talk
faster oh just talk fast Oh interesting
in my opinion so many people do podcasts
and they do it as if they're looking for
their keys
oh is that kind of like I'm thinking
about what I'm talking about as I'm
talking so it's not that rushed you got
to know what you're talking about I
never really pay attention to the speed
at which I'm speaking yeah I mean I do I
suppose just when you're given a time
frame and you have to do a certain
amount of jokes yeah you're not gonna
lollygag no that's right but I think in
podcasts people feel free to and it's it
makes it so boring and I'm gonna add to
that unsolicited advice to whoever out
there maybe maybe or maybe not needing
it don't say these people while they're
talking there and see like that yeah I'd
do it I don't think I'd do that
hey you don't unless you're actually
trying to think of something right but I
guess my point is like already have
thought of it if you're gonna record it
exactly right yeah because a lot of
podcasts are just come like a [ __ ]
mind-numbingly dull conversation like
this one sure exactly but there's a pace
that we keep with each other about it
you we there there's a lot of smoke and
mirrors to let you know we you know it
distract you from the fact that we're
really talking about the [ __ ] yes
you know thoroughly and one of those is
talking fast you say thing I immediately
say a thing and pretty soon no one knows
that we haven't talked about anything it
is as if we've always been talking about
it mm-hmm have you ever gone to yaki's
oh no makes me think of vomit what do
you think that guy's mopping up yeah
he's you know yakking is I mean where
I'm from that's
when you throw up that's vomit yeah I'm
not gonna eat there you gotta be careful
when you name a place it's true did you
know that the Nova didn't sell in Mexico
it was like the Nova's like one of
Chevy's best selling cars in America but
they tried to export it to Mexico women
didn't sell because Nova means no go and
meccans
oh wow no one did that research huh
no that's really funny in the 70s I mean
nobody did research yeah yet and explain
to me then the popularity of the dump
cake people love to [ __ ] and people love
to eat cake
done and done I like both those things -
who doesn't sometimes at the same time
I'll bring a piece of cake why see
there's the new out with the old it's
just yeah it's the infinity eight going
through you it's actually the shape of
my intestines they're all laying down
aids in your guts and then you've got
the lady Kathy Baker what's her name
Kathy something that does the
infomercial have you seen the dump cake
in firmer all right Sammy Baker Davis
jr. she she just does a box of cake mix
and then act like a diet coke and some
cheer yeah bro [ __ ] nuts
soda pop it is it is yeah that is that
was an early sign of you know what is
happening now I guess people loosely
call it the apocalypse yeah you know I
don't know but it is cuz there's a real
one that's like happening
environmentally but that'll take a while
I think we need to get over ourselves
and realize it just means we shouldn't
have kids because it's really gonna [ __ ]
them over yeah then there's also the one
where it's like well hurricanes and
fires all ok so then this is is there a
God then someone's ending it yeah some
powers that be
I don't one's doing something so I don't
know if it's a real environmental one or
if it's just like you know just and then
people it's all happening it was it's
all happening very fast but anyway that
infomercial for the dumb
cake was the an early sign pick your
favorite soda it's a with a box of cake
and some pineapple rings and then her
fat fingers putting the pineapple rings
down into the pan they're breathing as
she leans down to do it she puts on her
sleep mask keep breathing she just puts
pineapple rings in her nostrils to
alleviate thank you pineapple will help
your nostrils so you can breathe another
night your favorite setup found your pro
opening up a flower hole there are we at
a candy bar everything she brings in is
just like the grossest breakup of eggs
of all Brad no Kathy a list of things
that shouldn't be together exactly
together god I watch that on the old -
it's the best the old tube of me told
you to be the old YouTube well we're
coming up on your place anything you
want to plug oh yes you're just gonna be
in town for a while and you're gonna
relax and work on yourself I'm working
on myself I'm maybe I might get a job at
this Whole Foods when it opens oh yeah I
work in cigs yeah big sections face I've
always kind of wanted to be the guy in
charge of all those different olives
with your own little cart that's it that
thing that works like a specialty thing
these days yeah it's always fun here's
when there's some like a specialty I
don't like it when the salsa cart comes
up on me it's like yeah your job is too
specific
yeah moving along squeaky wheels
um yeah me too it does it's let's let's
just get ready for the holidays oh we
also have we're doing LA pod fest oh
yeah that'll be great if you are coming
we are doing that you're also doing one
for my favorite murder right that's
right it's the whole LA pod fest family
together again it's gonna be great
it's been a while I've only done it as a
guest so uh and then you'll see who our
guest is it'll be a surprise a fun
surprise for LA pod people yeah it'll be
great yeah yeah I did it for the first
time last year and it was awesome and
what are the dates it's in a couple
weeks
I don't remember we have an email we
have to answer yes yeah we'll do that
one it's okay and then you'll all know
after we answer that email yeah Chris
will dub it in out you're good all right
cool well it's good to see you again
friend you too my friend
yeah but let us see each other more
often okay good I'm around you've been
listening to a podcast called do you
need a ride DUI an AR oh that actually
[Music]
matter how much baggage you clean give
us time and made terminal and gate we
wanna stand you up inside we wanna
welcome you back home tell us all about
it we scared her was it fine now horn
[Music]
do you meet around
do you need a ride do you need a line do
you need a ride do you need a ride do
you need with Kern and Chris
you